[Musique]
inès gauthier à 15 ans depuis qu'elle
est gamine elle est passionnée par la
cuisine elle aime couper une mangue en
petits dés
écrasez l'ail avec la lame de couteau
manger une tartine de beurre camembert
elle aime surtout croquer dans un
chocolat et le laisser fondre dans sa
bouche
le chocolat c'est aussi moelleux
[Musique]
inès n'aime pas retiré le noyau d'un
avocat clarifier les j'ai toujours
parking au clic qui tombe dans mon plan
inès adore voyager royaume uni portugal
italie france martinique
ses parents lui ont fait découvrir le
monde et c'est ça va puis lui est venue
l'idée de jumeler ses passions et d'en
faire un livre de recettes et nas au
tour de l'inde c'est moi
c'est vraiment très bon dans le
magnifique site toits qu'il fait ça bien
sûr voyage partout on fait tous les
continents
on a ici en république dominicaine au
portugal en russie en corée du sud et
maman l'egypte est décrit moi c'est plus
alors on a eu la chance d'avoir un cours
de pêche utilisé natas au times note du
portugal
et c'est là où on a pris vraiment
comment faire les pastiches de natas si
on reste dans le sucre et ça c'est de la
mana on a le carpaccio d'ananas de
république dominicaine
si sûr qu'à chaque fois qu'on veut en
pointe à cannes c'est le dessert comme
enjeu souvent parce que c'est ananas
safran c'est sûr que ça match déjà là on
va faire un saut en egypte en egypte
j'ai une amie qui comme notre grande
soeur de coeur lionel et elle est l
égyptienne on est allé un jour manger
chez elle et elle nous a fait le fameux
affecté égyptiens et une salade
égyptienne et quand ça vient de sortir
du four avec encore le le gras de la
halle au gras de la viande c'est sûr que
quand tu mélanges tout ensemble et tu
prends une bouchée c'est exceptionnel
donc la salade de crevettes de corée du
sud
inès nous propose un voyage en corée du
sud avec une salade de crevettes épicé
et carottes puis pour terminer dès
varini kiss
les fameux varenikis ce oasis la recette
que j'adore j'ai eu aussi une gardienne
qui est russe et qui m'a appris comment
bien faire la pâte bien faire la purée
qui à l'intérieur parce que c'est de la
patate qui à l'intérieur
quand je goûte à un plat c'est sûr que
tu te demandes mais comment il est fait
c'est quoi la recette derrière et c'est
la curiosité voilà j'ai toujours été
curieuse depuis que tout petit savoir
comment le plat il est fait papa et
maman ils ont un entourage très variés
j'ai la chance de parler avec ces
gens-là de savoir leur culture de savoir
quelles sont leurs plats traditionnels
il n'y a pas que les grands qui
enrichissent le bagage culinaire d'inès
elle s'inspire aussi de ses amis pour
apprendre à cuisiner de nouveaux plats
bon aujourd'hui avec mon ami qui va et
on va faire un taquet mais pourquoi tu
as choisi cette race est non
c'est vraiment un repas traditionnel à
nice et ses p puis à petit en fait seul
lorsqu'on a des invités ça va être quoi
les étapes de tarsacq qu'est ce que tu
fais avec les oignons is union commence
par avec lui une voiture les oignons
on va couper le poulet dans des petits
morceaux on va cuire le poulet avec les
oignons on a utilisé puissance puis
après convient que le pool va commencer
à écrire avec c'est très important de
rester le riz au moins du trap avec
l'opinion valcke
si jamais monté des pythons à massy en
fait donc c'est vraiment au goût est la
leur et quoi aurais d'ascendant avec les
affaires iraniennes quand tu perds ce
côté un peu froid qu'est ce qui manque
ils paradent s'apprête donc là de milo
way sur le riz dont il fait cuire
complètement erie dans l'eau non on
laissait smic russe mi cuit par la suite
on va le remettre sur la culinaire avec
le poulet ça va finir de cuire jamais
compris c'est comme un gâteau elle
faisait comme un héros c'est comme un
gâteau puis pour que ça reste est de
coller ensemble c'est la convier mettre
les augures les yeux les oreilles ça
sera une chose sans s'affoler
enfin quand on salit
[Musique]
puis la foule de quincy oui et c'est ce
qu'on a fait notre iront le renverse
dans un autre plat puis on peut décorer
notre gâteau
merci ça non je suis trop fier de ce
qu'on appelle c'est michael beauty queen
s le bonheur est simple ce qui me fait
plaisir c'est de cuisiner des bons plats
du monde et de les déguster en bonne
compagnie qui vacille anglais se
souhaiter bon appétit en perte ce serait
quoi
on me dit c'est ta machine merci les
filles d'avoir permis le voyage est un
peu avec vous un pétrin chez beaucoup
[Musique]